can we just agree that where there's
smoke often there is fire
can we just agree that it is not a
blessing of liberty
to have transvestites twerking for
toddlers at the public library
conservative every conservative and and
just about every democrat would have
agreed with this
10 years ago not that long ago
but now because the slippery slope just
has a sliding on down because of that
even many conservatives now will say you
know well if we
ban drag queen story hour then they
might tell us we can't go to church
they're already telling you you can't go
to church they've been telling you that
for a year in many places in this
country
and and by the way if we can't
distinguish in this country
between twerking for toddlers
in drag and going to church if we
if we think those two things are
basically kind of the same right we
can't
make a moral judgment between them then
we can't make any kind of moral judgment
then we can't have any kind of political
vision because self-government relies on
the ability of the people
to to make these kinds of judgments for
themselves and then
implement that through self-government
another leftist leader of dubious morals
before we get to the mailbag sir major
page
32 years old was just invited indicted
rather he was invited to go to prison
by a federal grand jury in cleveland on
three counts of money laundering one
count of wire fraud according to the doj
page is uh the leader of the black lives
matter of greater atlanta facebook page
uh he created a 501c3 nonprofit
organization for this group
he raised almost a half million dollars
from donors
and you know how he spent that money
that was being given to him oodles of it
being given him for social justice
and racial justice he spent it on
his house on guns and on hookers
it was always a grift it was always a
con the blm organization
this is why the family of michael brown
and ferguson and other community leaders
in ferguson
are now demanding tens of millions of
dollars from the blm organization
because they want a little cut of the
action they want a piece of this
extortion ring that blm has been running
on corporate america and many other
people
for well over a year now it was always
a naked power grab some people gullible
gave into it
others did not meanwhile when they're
not blowing money on guns homes and
hookers
they're they're spending it to burn the
country down through the riots that we
saw
for for six to eight months in this
country
quite a slippery slope could you imagine
telling someone that this would happen
five ten years ago they wouldn't have
believed it the only way we're going to
stop these things is if we make
substantive moral claims which is an
argument i make in my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
available for pre-order until amazon
figures out what it's about and then
they'll take it off
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
[Music]